Lee is with us to start us off in
Houston Texas
hey Lee welcome to the show hello Dave
hi so what's your what is your net worth
we have right at 2.2 million 2.2 what's
that invested in most of it is my
husband's retirement clan its 1.6
million why it's 1.8 million ok 1.8 and
and what is that invested in mutual
funds or what yes and his he works for
an oil company so some of that is the
oil company stock and because he's older
now he's 59 it's in more of a
conservative allocation okay cool cool
and what has been your all's working in
your household income during your
working lifetime when you think your
average has been the average is probably
been the average has probably been about
90,000 because I stayed home for years
oh that's my kid and what is the income
now it's at 115,000 excellent how much
of this 2.2 million dollars did you all
inherit zero we inherited a grandfather
clock it tells you what time you can go
to work we have one parent on either
side still living ok that's awesome
alright and what was your husband's
career field he is an IT IT excellent ok
and does he have a degree
yes he does in what computer science NIT
ok
what was his GPA do you know it was a
3.8 he was a total nerd and how much of
this net worth was caused by you
borrowing money to your advantage
ok alright alright and what part does
giving play in your wealth building we
are faithful tithers
and and we also support a missionary and
they're just owned in some teach 5th and
6th grade Sunday schools they were
always working for causes at a church
and so we are faithful 10% on what Ivers
gotcha
what's the most expensive jeans either
you or your husband have ever bought
blue jeans
uh you know they can't be more than 25
36 and then we wear our clothes for
years thirty dollars and how many new
cars did you buy before you had a
million dollar net worth never a new car
zero I had it I had a company car once
it was new but that was the only new car
so what is your advice to the 24 year
old you 24 year old version of your
husband that's listening right now okay
it comes in just a few bullet points but
I'll keep it brief
first of all fully fund your retirement
account fully fund it fully finally
retire I know you know years go by and
all of a sudden you realize it's gotten
big the second thing is put a good
perspective on things because what I
realized now is if there's no space or
possession that can provide me with
fulfillment at all and and then the
other thing is we've just bought
everything used I mean even when the
kids were would always buy their clothes
so they bought cars news dishes views
you know we just at least save so much
money buying Jesus and and I've often
thought is I've observed peers and
people that I'm acquainted with from
what they spend on cars they could send
their kids to school at college there it
is
advice from someone with a 2.2 million
dollar net worth starting from nothing
at 59 years old how old are you I'm 50
okay that's 50 and 59 then we had our
kids late so we have one that just
entered college this year and then they
have a freshman in high school very cool
well thank you Lee you're a great
American success story you and your
husband
honored to speak to a real millionaire
and find out how it's really done not
what someone with a political agenda or
someone on a newscast is telling us it's
a real millionaire 2.2 million dollar
net worth 1.8 and mutual funds average
income of 90,000 high of 150 through
their working lifetime they didn't make
six million dollars a year
they didn't make five hundred thousand a
year they just saved and bought used
cars kind of like we teach you on the
Dave Ramsey show
it's a millionaire theme hour on the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show I want to write a
song I want to own my own business I
want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year so wish